carson wentz continues to be a
member of the philadelphia eagles then
again he would be through march 17 at 4
p.m eastern
anyway but the trade speculation is
running rampant it has centered
christopher
on the indianapolis colts and the
chicago bears howard eskim
who has been the radio sideline reporter
for the eagles for a
very long time yeah he's been a fixture
in the philadelphia media
he floated on saturday night rumor's all
over here's what i'm told
wentz and a draft pick to the bears for
the number one draft pick the chicago
bears hold not first overall their first
round pick
quarterback nick foles and running back
tarik cohen who's coming off with an acl
injury that should be ready in september
that was
a stunner to me look nick foles has been
acquired by the eagles two different
times already this would be number three
he's been a super bowl mvp
nick foles and jalen hurts instead of
carson wentz and jalen hurts i can kind
of get behind that just from an intrigue
standpoint
although i don't know why you fired doug
peterson if you're going to bring back
nick falls and get rid of carson wentz
it's just a weird vibe right now
throw on top of the nfl media report the
eagles aren't happy with the offers they
receive well what are you going to do
not trade him
i i feel like it's it's too late i feel
like the train's out of the station
you can't go back now yeah i mean yes i
mean one
i think that tells you that there was
more issues with the doug peterson thing
than just the carson wentz and the
quarterbacks right
you know the other thing with with just
this whole situation
you know wentz has got to get out of
philadelphia we we've talked about this
i i still believe that that there
it's a no-win situation so he can't want
to go back there
as soon as he plays one bad quarter or
one bad drive
the whole fan base is gonna say you
stink we should have never got rid of
nick foles
let's put jalen hurts back in blah blah
blah blah blah
he's in a no-win situation sea of
philadelphia for carson wentz he's got
to make sure that's that's real
now yeah colts and bears i mean colts
make a lot of sense we know that
frank reich being there he fits their
offense everything would be perfect
but yeah a guy like chris ballard he
ain't giving up like the the
the you know kitchen sink for carson
wentz you know that
like with carson wentz there's risk in
trading for him
mike you know there's risk in one it's a
lot of money
as you've mentioned many a times so
that's going to hurt his value as far as
what his trade is worth
but also there's a negative connotation
around carson wentz
if carson wentz goes to the colts and
this is why i would go bears i don't
really know why you want carson wentz
because you're going to get right back
in the trubisky conversation here
but if you get carson wentz in one of
these trades
and it doesn't go well at first
everyone's going to go
what the hell it didn't work that good
in philly did he really look that good
and
special in philly they didn't want him
we have guys that can't evaluate
quarterbacks what's going
risk in that because that is where the
public conversation is going to turn
as soon as he plays bad and for the
bears
it's already there that's where i go are
you sure you want carson once chicago
because if he doesn't play good the
first four or five weeks all they're
gonna go is
see ryan pace and matt nagy can evaluate
quarterbacks
and that's where i think it's a little
risky i don't know what chicago wants
i don't know either i don't think they
know what they want although they'd love
to go back to 2017 and draft patrick
mahomes instead of mitchell trubisky
but but i i agree with you for wentz
especially he shouldn't want to go to
chicago because it's
it's really yeah yeah you're stepping
into the same problem right
and there's more pressure on you to
perform right out of the gates in
indianapolis
i think he would have more leeway he'd
have more of a chance to grow and
develop
frank reich has built up enough equity
in three seasons on the job
that he could convince the fans to be
patient that this is a project
we're still in the post andrew luck what
the hell are we doing mode
right this is a project we've got the
cap space work with us on this so i
think that there's merit to that and i
think the colts make a lot more sense if
i'm once
i strongly prefer the colts over
the chicago bears and i was told he does
i was told by some people i trust that
he prefers the cult situation certainly
and but yeah you're right i mean to the
point where
you know the chicago one's so weird and
odd like you said i mean it really is
it's just like philly
oh you're going to go there and run the
same offense
and what they got some offensive line
issues right now
the whole city is questioning the
offense and how it works all together
and if the people can evaluate
the quarterback as the right is it the
right guy and all that type of stuff
and yes co you're you're exactly right
he'll be in the same situation there
with chicago i don't know why either one
would want each other really
and think about it you go into chicago
they go all in
with carson wentz he walks into hallas
hall
as the guy on whom everyone's job is
resting because if it falls apart
in 2021 in chicago
you think you think they're gonna have
another press conference at the end of
the season where
george mccaskey says ryan pace and matt
negro coming back i don't think so
so they got they got one shot they got
to make it work
and i don't know that carson wentz is
the guy to make it work with and here's
the other reality and this is why
i think it's funny how philadelphia is
trying to game this but
at least they're trying to they got
jared goff
light this is a situation far closer to
goff
than stafford yeah matthew stafford was
a guy that the rams
wanted jared goff was a hot potato that
the rams wanted to unload
that's why the lions got two ones and a
three they didn't get two ones and a
three for stafford
they got a one and a three for stafford
and the lions got
a one to take on the jared goff contract
wentz is far closer that there is value
to the eagles and they can try to they
can try to play the
the cards as close to the vest as they
can and howie roseman trying to
play the you know trying to get the the
advantage and make it look like they got
a lot for carson wentz at a certain
point you got to say you know what
you're getting for carson wentz you're
unloading 40 million dollars
off of your books that's what you're
getting for carson wentz so take what
you can get
and move on and get him to the cults you
don't want him to have his career
rebirth
with an nfc team i mean i think the
bears are the patsies in this i don't
think the bears are seriously part of it
it could be howard eskin is carrying
water for one of his employers i hate to
say that but hey
they signed one of his checks let's
let's goose the market by making it look
like the bears are at the table
just to get the colts to give more i
think all of this is noise
aimed at getting the colts to up their
offer
so the eagles can feel like they've
they've not lost
in this trade of carson once yeah maybe
maybe i i i don't get it that it's that
sense but you could be right i'm not
saying i know for sure here but
i i mean i i don't know i feel like
chicago has got to make some sort of
play maybe for the quarterback situation
it seems like they want to
you know but not carson wentz but i
think that's very risky
he shouldn't want to go there and they
shouldn't want it and i think it's a
recipe for disaster i agree
all all together the the colts one makes
a lot of sense it really does
and you know you laid it out there
pretty perfectly
and and i think that's why somebody like
chris ballard and frank reich are just
not gonna
sell off you know all their assets chris
ballard sees through it he sees
know what the goals are trying to do
right the eagles have no leverage
they've got the cults and the leverage
can't be the bears
if you get no they ain't going to
chicago and the leverage can't be well
we'll just keep him
it's too late to keep him it's too late
it's too late
so it's the unless somebody else looks
at
some game film from 2017 and says we
gotta have carson wentz they gotta do
the best deal they can with the colts
and move on or they're going to have an
even bigger problem as they try to get
nick ciriani
off on the right foot hi i'm mike tarico
and thanks for watching
make sure to hit subscribe for the
latest news and highlights
from nbc sports